[موسيقى]
ما وراء الافلام مع محمود النجار على
العربيه بودكاست
الصحافه كلها بتتكلم عن بطل خارق بيظهر في
عالمنا بس المره دي مش بيطير ولا بيطلع
اشاعه من عينيه انسان عادي زيه بس تصرفاته
ما كانتش علي ضحى بنفسه علشان ينقذ فريقه
كلامنا عن البطل فيلبس ايه اللي حصل وليه
تتحول قصته الفيلم في 2013 باسم كابتن
فيلبس ده اللي هاحكي لك عنه النهار ده انا
محمود النجار وانت بتسمع فودكا الافلام
المقدمه للعربيه
[موسيقى]
وهحكي لك عن ما وراء كابتن فيلبس
في بدايه الفيلم هتشوف كابتن فيليبس بيودع
امراته وبيبدا يجهز لرحلته اللي جايه
رحلته من صلاله في عمان لمومباسا في كينيا
بيجهز الكابتن هو وفريقه وبتبتدي رحله
سفينه حاويات مارسك اليمامه بنشوف الفيلم
ان فيلبس بيجي له تحذيرات ان البحر فيه
قرصنا وقتها بيطلب فورا ان الفريق يعمل
تدريبات في حاله هجوم قراصنه وبدعو
بالفعلوا يعملوا تدريبات على اطفاء
الحرائق ولكن في الوقت ده
ظهر القرصناه وكانوا على بعد سبع اميال بس
وقتها في لبس بيتصرف تصرف ذكي جدا
وبيستخدم جهاز راديو لتزييف مكالمه ما
بينه وما بين البحريه الامريكيه على امن
القراصنه يكونوا بيسمعوا المكالمه
ويعتقدوا ان في مساعده جايه في الطريق
ويرجعوا فعلا نجحت الطريقه دي بس في
البدايه لكن بعدها بيرجع ده اللي هتشوفه
في الفيلم لكن في الحقيقه القراصنه كانوا
اقرب من سبعه عميال والفريق كله اتعرض
للخطر وهيحاولوا يصدوا الكراستنه
ويستخدامه خراطيم اطفاء الحريق بس للاسف
على الرغم من المحاولاتهم دي القرصنه
قدروا يدخلوا السفينه والمكالمه المزيفه
معملتش حاجه غير انها اخرتهم وده بسبب
قرارات فيليبس ان هو يكمل في البحر وفي
الاتجاه ده على السفينه اربع قراصنه
مسلحين وكل اللي فيها رجال مش مسلحين ولا
مدربين على مواقف زي دي هيكون ايه العمل
في الفيلم بيظهر كابتن فيلبس وهو بيتتبع
بدقه بروتوكولات السلامه وبيؤمر الفريق
بيقفلوا كل حاجه لحد ما يوصله في الحقيقه
ده ما حصلش وقال كبير المهندسين مايك بيري
ان الكابتن ما قفلش الجسر وهو كان عارف ان
القراصنه على ظهر السفينه وقتها اضطر
الفريق ان هو ينزل تحت وحبسهم في غرفه
المحرك وفضلوا فيها 12 ساعه في درجه حراره
130 اما فيلبس وثلاثه من الفريق فكانوا
تحت تهديد السلاح من القراصنه فيلبسوارات
تحت تهديد السلاح في محاوله منه ان هو
يخلي القراصنه يمشوا عرض عليهم 30,000
دولار بس هم كانوا عايزين اكثر من ده
بكثير في القصه الحقيقيه اللي حصل فعلا بس
بعد ما البحريه ضربوا النار على القرصنا
الصوماليين واخده قريب النجاه ما لقوش اي
اثر ل 30,000 دولار اثناء وجود القراصنه
جوه السفينه بداوا يدوروا على الطقم
المستخبي وهنا بتبدا رحله الفريق في ان هو
ينجو بنفسه في ظروف ما كانوش مستعدين لها
تماما لكنهم على الاقل بيحاولوا في الفيلم
بتشوف الفريق وهو بيحط على الارض ازاز
متكسر جوه اوضه المحرك علشان لما القرصنا
يدخلوا يتصابوا وبالفعل ده بيحصل وده اللي
خلاهم قادرين ياخذه واحد من القرصنه خلينا
اقول لك ان في الواقع ده ما حصلش وفيلبس
ما نزلش مع القرصنا لكنه بعث احد من الناس
اللي كانوا معه فوق واللي قدر ياخذ
القرصان
والقدر ياخذ القرصان كراهينه فعلا كان
كبير المهندسين مايك بيري مشكله الفيلم
الحقيقيه ان هو بيحاول يظهر في كل مشهد قد
ايه الكابتن فيلبس بطل وان هو ده حب نفسه
علشان الطقم بتاعه ولما قال في 1 اتش
لو عايز تضرب النار على احد اضرب عليا كل
ده مش حقيقي لان القبطان الحقيقي ريتشات
فيلبس ما عرضش ابدا يتخلى عن حياته
المقابل الطقم بتاعه وعلشان كده الطقم
السفينه ميرسك الاباما مش شايفينه بطل
بالعكس رفع 11 من افراد الطقم دعوه قضائيه
ضد شركه مارسك على باما وشركه ووتر ستام
شيبردشن بحوالي 50 مليون دولار وقالوا ان
الشركه كان عندها تجاهل متعمد لسلامتهم
وكانوا شايفين ان فيلبس قبطان متهور وهو
اللي قادهم للبحر في حته فيها قراصنه لان
وقتها كان بيوصل لكل كابتن بريد الكتروني
في تحذيرات من هجمات القراصنه الصوماليين
في المنطقه وكان من ضمن الشروط ان السفن
اللي لازم تحافظ على مسافه تزيد عن 600
ميل بحري من الساحل الصومالي وسفنجه كانت
على بعد 300 ميل بس في افاده سنه 2012
اعترف الكابتن فيلبس انه ارى تحضيرات
البريد الالكتروني واعترف كمان انه احتفظ
بالتحذيرات دي لنفسه وفي الوقت اللي كانت
في عمليه الخطف شغاله زوجته اندريه صرحت
في مقابله لها مع وكاله ان وصل لها بريد
الكتروني من زوجها بيقول فيه ان النشاط
القراصنه بينتشر في المنطقه ولما اتسال
فيلبس ليه ما بقتش عن الشاطئ قال له انه
ما كانش معتقد 600 ميل اللي هيفرق في حاجه
يعني او هيخلي الطقم بتاعه في امان لكن
انه اكتشف العكس وبصراحه على رغم ان
الفيلم ازهر كابتن فيلبس كبطل الا ان
كابتن فيليبس نفسه قال ان مش معتبر نفسه
بطل خالص على الرغم ان الفيلم حره في كثير
من الواقع الا انه في الحقيقه نقل مشاهد
كتير مميزه وهتعلق معك لما تشوفها خاصه
المشاهد اللي كانت جوه قوارب النجاه ازاي
في لبس كان بيتعاطف مع القرصان الصغير في
السن خاصه انه قد ابنه او انه كتب ملاحظه
لعيلته اثناء اختطفه وبعيدا عن الشخصيه
الحقيقيه ما عملتش الكلام ده بس تصرف توم
هانكس كان مؤثر جدا وتفكيره في عيلته
واندفاعه ان هو يهرب كل ده هتقف عنده
وتفكر ازاي قدر يعمل كده وهو تحت الحديد
السلاح في الفيلم بنشوف احتجاز فيلبس لمده
يوم ونصف تقريبا بس في الحقيقه هو اتحجز
لمده خمس ايام وتم انقاذه يوم الاحد 12
ابريل 2009 بعد ما كان على الاقارب النجاه
من يوم الاربعاء ولو بتسال على مصير
القراصنه وايه اللي حصل لهم خلينا اقول لك
ان الثلاثه منهم ماتوا واللي فضل كان عبد
المولى عبد القادر موسى واتحكم عليه بثلاث
و30 سنه في السجن الفيدرالي وبسبب عمره
عائلته رفعت قضيه وقالوا ان هو اقل من 18
سنه والمفروض يتعاقب كاحداث وقت حجزه حاول
موسى ان هو ينتحر كذا مره ومن الحاجات
اللي محتاجه اقولها لك ان في مخرج فيلم
وثائقي عن موسى بعنوان سمايلينج كارت ولا
ان هم حاولوا ان هم اكثر من مره يقابلوه
لكنه كان بيرفض بسبب انه كان معتقد ان هم
هيصوروه على انه الشخص السيئ والحقيقه
حياه القراصنه لها ابعاد بشكل مختلف فيلم
كابتن فيلبس لما نزل ناقل اعجاب المشاهدين
سواء غيره في الحقيقه كثير او لا ده في
النهايه قدره ينقلوا ازاي البحاره
بيواجهوا مخاطر كثير شوف الفيلم دلوقتي
ويقول لي ايه اكثر مشهد عجبك فيه وسنان
الحلقه اللي جايه فيلم جديد من بودكاست
مارا الافلام
[موسيقى]